it's hard to imagine but just 300 years
ago it was widely believed that insects
spontaneously spawned from dust mud or
rotten meat
their reproduction was felt to be so
strange and frightening they were known
as beasts of the devil
it's partly thanks to the work of
naturalist and illustrator maria sabila
marion that we can now find this idea
amusing
today marion is celebrated as one of the
world's first ecologists she is admired
by sir david attenborough who described
her as one of the most significant
contributors to entomology the study of
insects
but she faced many challenges in her
journey to educate the world not least
because of her sex
born into a family of artists in
frankfurt in 1647
marion spent her childhood collecting
insects and drawing them in remarkable
detail
in 1665 she married and soon had two
daughters
in an age where a woman's place was
thought to be in the home she defied
convention publishing her first book new
book of flowers in 1675
[Music]
marion was one of the first to describe
the metamorphosis of insects in detail
declaring that all moths and butterflies
hatch from eggs after reproduction and
do not just magically appear
in 1699
marion by then divorced sold her
belongings and set sail to suriname in
south america with one of her daughters
dorothea
she is thought to be the first woman to
travel in the name of science
[Music]
after a long sea journey they set off
into the jungle battling through thick
clouds of black flies that inflicted
skin ripping bites but it was worth it
the jungles of suriname were in
naturalists paradise
teeming with species that would later be
documented in marion's groundbreaking
work the metamorphosis of the insects of
suriname published in 1705
its stunning illustrations depicted
stages of development of suriname's
voracious caterpillars and vibrant
butterflies as well as many other
creatures from this exotic habitat
uniquely for the time she also portrayed
insects surrounded by the plants they
relied on revealing their relationship
to the wider ecosystem
she was the first to show that the
change from caterpillar to butterfly
depended on a number of plants
though she had planned to stay longer
marion's adventure was cut short by
illness and after two years she returned
to amsterdam
given the challenges of working in a
humid and unfamiliar environment it is
remarkable how many species she was able
to observe and catalogue in that time
[Music]
her writing is also notable for
acknowledging the mistreatment of
enslaved indigenous and african people
and their contribution to her research
she wrote in her description of the
peacock flower
the indians who are not treated well by
their dutch masters use the seeds to
abort their children so that they will
not become slaves like themselves
marion suffered a stroke in 1715 that
left her unable to work
she died two years later age 69
however marion's legacy has endured
to date at least six plants nine
butterflies two bugs a spider and a
lizard have been named after her despite
being over 300 years old her work on the
biodiversity of suriname is still valued
by scientists
and could show us how some species may
adapt to climate change
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video